when you think about a mad scientist who
do you think of how about dr. Jacqueline
or Doc Brown maybe a few characters from
comic books okay maybe more than a few
from comic books chances are though
there's one name that came to mind first
Frankenstein Mary Shelley's mad man with
a love for the electric has become the
ultimate warning of a science experiment
gone wrong but this tale of Terror has
done more than shocked audiences it may
also have been the spark of inspiration
for a medical device keeping four and a
half million people on this planet alive
let's find out how the science fiction
inspired science reality so what's the
connection between this monster and a
pacemaker to explain that we have to go
back to the 1700s when electricity was a
subject of fascination and scientists
were testing its effects on human bodies
Luigi Galvani discovered in the 1780s
that electric current cost a dead frog's
leg to twitch in 1803 Galvani's nephew
Giovanni aldini conducted experiments on
the corpses of criminals in which a jolt
of electricity to the head seemed to
cause the body to reanimate Mary Shelley
heard about these experiments through
her circle of writer and scientist
friends influencing her novel
Frankenstein about a scientist obsessed
with the secret of life
dr. Victor Frankenstein assembles body
parts and uses a jolt of electricity to
bring them to life
[Music]
Frankenstein published in 1818 and is
considered both gothic horror and early
science fiction the movie version
starring Boris Karloff premiered in 1931
and it inspired a young Earl Bakken to
work with both electricity and medicine
he would later say what intrigued me the
most as I sat through the movie again
and again was the creative spark of dr.
Frankenstein's electricity in 1957
Bakken developed the first wearable
battery-powered cardiac pacemaker a
device that uses electric pulses to
correct abnormal heartbeats his company
Medtronic would go on to create many
different kinds of pacemakers and they
remain one of the most commonly used
pacemakers today
and it all started a little spark of
creativity from a boy watching his
favorite sci-fi
[Music]
[Music]